let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads
explode let me be clear before this
podcast begins
we are loud proud and
do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not
liberty you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] ah
the smell of freedom of speech this is
the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
good afternoon everybody
welcome to episode 15 of let's talk the
tony michaels podcast
we have a specific thing to talk about
today and it happened yesterday
later in the afternoon we got a verdict
[Music]
in the derrick chauvin trial
of the murder of george floyd we
received
a verdict on all three counts
he was found guilty uh they read the
verdict
and they remanded his bail very quickly
put him in cuffs and walked him straight
to the county jail
because he was guilty on all three
charges
um there was a lot of celebration uh
in the town of minneapolis and all
around the country and all around the
world
for the justice that was done for george
floyd and his family
for his murder because derek
chauvin thought it was his prerogative
as a police officer
to assault him with his knee put his
knee on his
neck until he was dead
and he was wrong as against the law as
murder
it's been shown that it is second degree
murder
and it gets you a guilty charge
it took the the jury 10 hours to
deliberate
on this issue which some say oh that's
not enough time to deliberate
well we had a trial for almost two weeks
that these juries
paid specific attention to and specific
testimony
on not only the videos but the evidence
uh
the autopsy and all the other tests that
was piled onto
this case
because derek chovin decided
made the decision to use excessive force
and not only decided to use excessive
force
use excessive time with that excessive
force
and the video shows it and really folks
i mean we wouldn't even be sitting here
talking about this
if some of those bystanders wouldn't
have stopped wouldn't have been
outraged at the scene and decided to
whip out their cell phone and start
recording this thing
because the body cam video is from the
perspective
of the police officers which may or may
not
somewhat disagree or agree may or may
not show
the evidence that the video from the
bystanders
uh perspective did now
that is one of the contentions the right
wing media has lost their
[ __ ] minds here i mean just
absolutely lost their minds because as
confident as i was about
at least two of these charges uh the the
third degree charges that they had
uh that they had charged derek chovin
with
the manslaughter and the murder where uh
the manslaughter just needed to show
assault i was pretty confident that the
jury was going to come back
with at least guilty with one baby two
uh it was
uh very reassuring to know that they did
come back with three in ten hours
apparently the jury watched the tape
from front to back
that's really what they wanted to see
was the tape now a lot of the people in
the right wing media are
bitching about a lot of things
in this trial i mean this has been going
on for two weeks
and they've been spinning narratives and
spinning narratives
and and and puking up propaganda
as they go along here and they continue
to
puke up propaganda because their
goal in puking up this propaganda about
uh uh george floyd having an overdose
and
you've seen these [ __ ] manga trump
humping [ __ ]
[ __ ] for brains in these comment threads
whenever someone posts something about
this trial or post something about the
death of george floyd
they they would be in the comments
section like crazy overdose overdose
overdose
overdose
well they're regurgitating this [ __ ]
from people like tucker carlson
full stop regurgitating this stuff from
fox news
tucker carlson and all these other
morons
out there that that clearly clearly
we're not going based on facts and we're
not developing their arguments
based on any of the [ __ ] evidence at
all
because if you waited for the trial to
make your decision
on on drug overdose or no drug overdose
and you clearly watch the witnesses that
the prosecution brought you would be
very confident to say that
yes george floyd was a drug user
but that doesn't matter
he still [ __ ] killed him he murdered
him
why does it matter if he uses drugs or
not
and i did a tick tock on this and of
course i posted on twitter and
uh you know it kind of explains give you
a little bit of analogy
of this drug overdose thing and i think
i played it last week or the week before
on here but i want to play it again
here in a minute uh uh and and kind of
give a again of a synopsis of
why that's all [ __ ]
the video does a really good job but and
then i did a video today
that i want to play for you about these
arguments from the right-wing media
because george floyd and his family have
now received
justice uh everyone wants to make this
about the world or
something else and it is i mean it is
you know the black lives matter movement
and
to make sure that this does not happen
again
now i don't think we can prevent it from
ever happening again but i think we can
move forward
uh based on the facts and the evidence
and the conviction uh
and hopefully in the next eight weeks
the sentencing of derek chovin
that we can we can move forward
uh joe biden even said that he wants to
move this george floyd policing bill
through the senate um which
which that's probably a whole other
podcast where we're talking about that
bill specifically
which hopefully it can have its day on
the floor in the senate but right now at
the filibuster
that just doesn't seem like it's going
to be possible so we need in the
filibuster
first that's a common theme in the
filibuster and you can get a lot of [ __ ]
done
wouldn't you know but
i'd like to start with that video that i
did a while back on
the overdose and how this is a dumb
[ __ ] argument because the right wing
has continued this this tirade about how
george floyd had fentanyl in his system
and he was gonna die
anyway so what's his life worth it's all
[ __ ] so let me play that and when
i'll see on the other side
death penalty what the [ __ ]
let's talk apparently there's some [ __ ]
bags in this country that think if a
person has a drug in their system
that warrants the death sentence you
dumb [ __ ]
really the case or is it that the person
who has drugs in their system
happens to be black hey your crusty
white grandpa is about to have back
surgery and for the pain he's prescribed
some [ __ ] opioids
stoked up one morning walks into a
convenience store and happens to pass a
fake 20 dollar bill
show up they try to get grandpa on the
back of the cruiser and because of his
prescription paranoia he doesn't want to
go in the right thing to do with these
[ __ ] bags mine is to throw grandpa on
the ground and kneel on him until he's
dead
because he was gonna die anyways we say
that the death of krusty white grandpa
was justified i didn't think so
stop beating around the bush you [ __ ]
you think george floyd should have died
because he's black
you racist [ __ ] [ __ ] him
and i mean every goddamn word of that
still
every [ __ ] last word of that i i
still
stand by my statements and the reason
why is because you have these these
knuckleheads
in the right wing media fox news ben
shapiro
candace owens tucker [ __ ] carlson you
even have politicians weighing in
on why there were no riots
they're pissed off that there's no riots
they're [ __ ]
infuriated that there's no riots they're
absolutely infuriated
and the reason why is because they keep
spinning this this narrative a
mob rule they keep saying oh well the
mob
the mob they were scared of the mob they
were scared of this and they were scared
of that and
it was the mob that caused this what
they mean by mob
is black lives matter protest
people protesting for their civil rights
that's what they mean and they were
hoping
they were hoping that there would be a
riot that's what they were hoping for
because
then oh my god then they can make them
the enemy
look see what happens because
ron desantis was even on fox news saying
hey
hey the jury you can't trust the jury
because the jury was tainted
you can't trust the courts you can't
trust a trial you can't
trust the evidence this is all an
extension of the big lie folks they did
the same
[ __ ] with voting same thing with voting
same god damn thing this is just an
extension of it that's all it is
well mail and ballots you can't trust
those absentee well i don't know about
their mail in ballots
and mailing ballots might not count we
can't what if dead people vote
what if dead people vote where's the
evidence that that dead people didn't
vote
if there's no evidence that dead people
didn't vote then there must be evidence
that there is
look at all these affidavits that people
sign to say that there was fraud even
though there's
really no fraud but they signed an
affidavit saying there was
oh we lost oh no we lost well let's
change the law so that
people that are likely to vote against
us are less likely to vote let's do that
let's [ __ ] let's [ __ ] about a law in
one state because we're losing in that
state
but when it's in another state and we're
winning what's the difference who cares
who cares that in states like colorado
they mail an application for a mail-in
ballot to a hundred percent of
registered voters
we're not even gonna bring that up
[Music]
when we're talking about the mlb moving
to colorado
because you know access to the ballot in
colorado is
is the same as georgia it's not
it's [ __ ] lies
so they continued on their little lie
train and build on the big lie and have
an extension
because they know is they know what's
gonna happen here
they know it their fascist
authoritarian [ __ ]
is gonna cause a lot of [ __ ] legal
obligations
a lot of them criminal civil there's
gonna be a ton of this [ __ ] in court
folks
a ton of it
trump criminals trump allies the trump
administration
people who were tied to the trump
administration who tried to help him
cheat and win in the last election
and when that didn't work they blamed it
on someone else
[Music]
sounds familiar with this
well they didn't get the outcome that
they wanted
for the derek chovan trial so because he
murdered george floyd so let's just
blame it on the mob
let's just blame it on the mob there
wasn't a mob
there was no mob there wasn't there was
protesters
peaceful protesters but there was no mob
this is all [ __ ] it's all lies
and they want it and it ain't for us
folks
and by when i say us i mean people who
are tethered to reality
that's not what this that's not what
this political theater is
for this right-wing media propaganda
political theater [ __ ]
is for the manga q anon trump humpers
that's who it's for and they've gone all
in with their with their little bow tie
boy tucker carlson
so why don't i go to that that video
and then maybe i'll break down each one
of these stupid
[ __ ] arguments of why they're uh why
it's unfair
that we had a trial and he was found
guilty on all three charges
i mean any other trial let me say this
if derek chovin would have been found
innocent of all three
they would be they would be praising the
court
it would be praising the jury
is what they would be doing they would
be saying see the legal process worked
is what they would say but because they
didn't get the fascist outcome that they
want
they're saying oh we should doubt that
we should doubt the criminal justice
system here
we should doubt the jury we should doubt
we should doubt
doubt doubt doubt don't believe it here
here's another narrative to believe
believe that the jury was scared
believe that the jury was scared let's
use
fear fear will get us there
let's do that
so i'm gonna play this video this tick
tock that i made today
and i'll talk about it on the other side
we'll get to the list of all this
[ __ ]
well some [ __ ] all three counts
let's talk jury finishes deliberations
in the jarrod chauvin trial of the
murder of george floyd
and they decided one two three you're
guilty [ __ ]
the right-wing media is [ __ ] pissed
told you this is gonna [ __ ] happen
this does not help their lies at all
jesus
[ __ ] cry why are the [ __ ] fascist
pissed you say
well let's run on down the list shall we
pissed because there was no riots
they wanted riots pissed now that the
justice system
seems rigged against them white people
pissed because their propaganda didn't
work on the jury like they wanted it too
really pissed that someone was standing
there with a cell phone filming derek
shavin murdering george floyd
god damn it pissed that no one's gonna
want to be cops cause they can't kill
black people anymore
[ __ ] keep going it's all part of the
plan right
[ __ ] them so
a lot of this you know nonsense uh
perpetuates from
from fox news in particular tucker
carlson but he's not the only actor here
but it's easy to use tucker carlson as a
punching bag
because he is a white supremacist
fascist full stop and he's not even
hiding it anymore
i mean he's he's all but said yeah
immigration in this country is for white
replacement
which is what got the nazi party in
power in
germany that's what they convinced the
population of
folks that there was a white replacement
okay that's what happened
there were jews in russia and they
scared people
in germany saying look the jews from
russia did it in russia
and rep did a did a voting replacement
that's what they're doing here is white
replacement
it's the same [ __ ] it's the same fascist
[ __ ]
same [ __ ] [ __ ]
beware beware look up what fascism is go
look up the [ __ ] definition
it's not that difficult anymore we got
the google machine
it's real simple
speaking of that looking up stuff on the
google machine
the the video they want to harp on the
video
they're saying this is why the entire
time the defense
was blaming the crowd for the death of
george floyd
they were blaming the crowd they were
blaming the bystanders
that's what it was
they were blaming the bystanders for
taking video
and they didn't want those videos they
wanted to discredit the bystanders to
discredit their videos
is what they wanted because
the the video from the body cams does
not show the same video
from the bystanders perspective it
doesn't
now there's also security cameras but
they act like
they act like that that this jury
saw only only the bystander video
that's it only the bystander video and
that is just
[ __ ] false that's all [ __ ]
[ __ ] i watched a lot
of the trial not all of it but a [ __ ]
lot of it and a lot of the testimony
and almost every single bit of the
testimony
from the majority of the witnesses when
they were giving video
as the evidence to testify on almost
all of it was body cam video almost all
of it
and the reason why is because there's a
shitload more
of footage from the body cams than there
is from bystanders
a shitload more way more
and the reason why is because their body
cans are on from the moment they arrived
until it was done
and there was four five six i mean there
were several officers at different
points
so this this [ __ ] narrative this this
absolute [ __ ] that
oh all the the video they only harped on
one that's all [ __ ]
that's all [ __ ] that's a [ __ ] lie
that's a [ __ ] lie this jury
looked at a hell of a lot more video
than just the one goddamn video that we
all saw
that created the outrage
and thank god for her for recording that
video
because if not did you did you see the
[ __ ] statement
that the minneapolis police was gonna
put out that day
it was a medical incident it was a
medical incident
because an ambulance was called
i didn't say anything about the
excessive use of force or use of force
at all anyways in the [ __ ]
report they were gonna just whitewash
right all over it
until that video surfaced and that was
the end of that
so thank god for her
and the body cams were the majority of
the video evidence
it was the majority and really there was
only one point in the body cam evidence
there's two but there's only one point
in the body cam evidence
that really the prosecution could cause
any doubt in the first place
and that was the exact moment when derek
chavin
lifted his knee off his neck
well is his leg on his shoulder
is his knee on his neck from this angle
what does it look like
they continued this this nonsense about
this one little moment in this video
about how derek shovings knee his leg
was on his shoulder
well i went over this the last week
is his knee was on his [ __ ] neck and
the knee bone is connected to the
leg bone the neck bones connected to the
shoulder bone so
obviously obviously if derek shoving's
knee was
on george floyd's [ __ ] neck lower
middle upper neck on his neck
then his leg was gonna be touching his
[ __ ] shoulder
i mean it doesn't take a full [ __ ]
anatomy lesson to realize that
that when you have your knee on
someone's neck
your leg is gonna touch their shoulder
of course it is
of course they kept harping on that one
thing
and then there was another moment in the
in the body cam video that they kept
coming back to which was when they
get george floyd on the ground they were
trying to straighten his legs out and he
kicked at them
which i don't even i don't i don't see
how
george floyd when they tried to
straighten out his legs because they had
him crouched down and he kicks a little
bit
justifies death but maybe you're a
heartless piece of [ __ ]
and that's what you think
because obviously you think if someone's
got drugs in their system
the officer has the right to kill them
regardless yeah you could kill them [ __ ]
them
so their next their next little [ __ ] is
that there wasn't any riots they're
really i mean they are infuriated about
this
they are infuriated that this verdict
didn't go their way and people didn't
burn down this country
because that's really what they wanted
that's what they wanted
they wanted the mob to come for the
country
and to burn stuff down you know like
break into a capitol building when the
government's trying to do
the thing that it does based on the
constitution and beat up
police officers and kill them and get
killed themselves
and get charged with handfuls of federal
felonies because they want to overturn
the constitution of the united states
you mean like that kind of mob what the
[ __ ] are you talking about
you people are are making excuse after
excuse after excuse
for the seditious insurrection this
treason
[ __ ] trump pumping fascist
that tried to overthrow our government
you're making every excuse you can
for them
but but oh boy oh boy there's a ma
there's mob rule out there be careful
you
white people there's mob rule wink
wink give me a [ __ ] break we know
what you're saying
desantis we know what you mean when you
pass a law
that gives you the ability to beat the
hell at a at a peaceful protesters you
think it makes it legal
for you to oppress the rights of other
people
that is not liberty the freedom to
oppress the rights of other people
is not liberty you [ __ ] [ __ ] eating
[ __ ]
look up liberty
so they didn't get their riots they
didn't get their mobs they didn't get
their buildings burned to the ground
they really wanted that footage they
really i mean they wanted it bad
fox news wanted that footage so [ __ ]
bad
they wanted it bad now the next thing
they go to the next thing they're
bitching about already is the criminal
justice system is
is rigged um you know same this is the
same old [ __ ]
same old [ __ ]
the same old [ __ ] that they did
about the election again this is what i
was just talking about a minute ago it's
an extension
they're saying all the criminal justice
is rigged against
us now we
we are not too far off folks we are not
too far off from these
[ __ ] q anon maga trump humping
[ __ ]
from saying things like well what's so
bad about fascism
what's so bad about it well if that's
what fascism is well i guess we should
consider it
we are this close we are this [ __ ]
close to that
to them just fully embracing and not
only embracing it but calling themselves
fascist
and saying stuff like well if that's
what fascism is well then it's not so
bad
maybe the nazis had it right maybe they
just did it wrong
we are not that far off folks we're not
that far off from this
because they are having an extension to
make sure that their supporters do not
trust any decisions that go against what
they think should be
out of the criminal justice system
that's where they're at
no matter what it is no matter what
now i'm not saying that we shouldn't
question the criminal justice system
we should question it
but to absolutely absolutely say that we
can't trust
jury trials that is [ __ ] un-american
that's [ __ ] un-american is what that
is
that's anti-democratic that is fascist
mr ron desantis you piece of [ __ ]
the right-wing media tucker carlson ben
shapiro
candace owens and the like the other
thing that they're really [ __ ] pissed
off about here about this
trial that they're infuriated about
and they're pro they keep projecting
good god
don't they know that we can tell that
they're projecting
they're on this tirade about how the
the left-wing media and maxine waters
and joe biden they convinced this
jury to have a
uh guilty on all three counts because
they were terrified of what would happen
to the country
i i don't know if i need to say much
more i mean number one
this whole thing about with maxine
waters you know they want to make her
out that
oh she was threatening a mob she was
threatening violence
she was she was she was in a crowd in a
rally
and she said storm down to the capitol
and and make sure they don't
wait a second that was someone else that
was someone else
give me a [ __ ] break
give me a [ __ ] break and the only
time joe biden said anything about this
trial was after the jury was sequestered
in the first place so get the [ __ ] over
yourselves
but that's not their point what they're
projecting
about how they think that the left-wing
media and these politicians like maxine
waters and joe biden
they influence the jury what they mean
is
is damn it our propaganda didn't work to
influence the jury
we tried so hard we tried so
hard to influence the jury and it didn't
work
i mean we went on for weeks and weeks
and weeks and weeks about a drug
overdose and they didn't buy any of that
we even force fed force fred the defense
of what
what arguments to make in court so that
way
the white dudes on the jury would have
some doubt and we could hang
the jury and then there would be no
verdict and the cop would go
free for weeks and weeks and weeks and
weeks and weeks and months and months
and months
they went through what the defense's
argument was gonna be
they force-fed it to him it was obvious
that's what was happening
and their propaganda didn't work
and that pisses them off
because their propaganda isn't working
like it used to
and they're mad they're mad that their
propaganda isn't working
they're mad oh they're not believing it
anymore what shall we do
well say fascist things
that's what you should do and that's you
know a lot of people
um are terrified here of of fox news and
tucker carlson i see this on twitter all
the time
that they need to take him off the air
they need to
shut him up and remove fox news which
the problem is is that we we live
in a society that our media
is relying on capitalism and as long as
our media is relying on capitalism
there's always going to be a market for
fear-based right-wing media
always no matter what we do even if we
have a fairness doctrine there's still
still gonna be
they're still gonna find a [ __ ] slimy
ass corner to congregate in
and to to sling these ideas back and
forth
now tucker carlson is an obvious white
supremacist
it's obvious he's not even hiding it
anymore
i mean you know he beat around the bush
for a while and you know he played
toyed with this thing but it's getting
pretty goddamn
thick here you fascist [ __ ]
you know the whole white replacement and
i mean just on and on and on
there's a thousand examples but listen
folks
if tucker carlson goes off fox news
tucker carlson is gonna go someplace
else and peddle his white supremacy
someplace else
and it all stems from this q anon stuff
and the reason why they
love this q anon stuff not just not just
tucker carlson and fox news
but the former president united states
that [ __ ] donald trump the reason why
they love
q anon the reason why they love it is
because these people will believe
anything they need to believe to believe
that they're the good guys because they
believe in this good guy bad guy [ __ ]
it's good versus evil [ __ ] they believe
that full stop they base their entire
[ __ ] belief off of this [ __ ]
and that's why q anon is so rooted in
white supremacy
that's the roots of it
and they love it not just the cueing on
people i'm talking about the people who
are perpetuating these lies
the reason why is because they're making
just [ __ ] mountains of money off
these people
those people don't know it help a lot of
people that don't even self identify
as q anon you know
you know the type they'll say all the q
anon stuff
but when you say the work you and i'm
like i don't believe that those people
are crazy
those people are nuts i'm cueing on
people
well you just said you believe all the
stuff they believe just because you
don't identify as them what the [ __ ]
i mean this is this is very a very close
example
and i have some real life experience
with this
when uh you guys remember the west
bureau baptist church
from kansas they would go protest at
soldiers funerals you know
hold up signs that say god hates [ __ ]
and you know
all this nonsense and you know you talk
to a christian
and you'd say you bring up westborough
baptist church and they might say things
like oh those people oh my gosh
i can't believe they protest they
protest soldiers funerals
like we do you know why and i asked i
asked
people who would say [ __ ] like that this
question do you know why they're
protesting the soldier's funeral
no why would they do such a thing i said
well the reason why they're protesting
the soldier's funeral isn't because
they're against a soldier
it's because they think that because
there's gay
people god is punishing the earth by
killing soldiers because there's gay
people
well i mean that doesn't sound so i mean
that that makes sense
yeah you believe what they believe
you're just not willing to hold the
[ __ ] sign that says god hates [ __ ]
you're not willing to hold a sign just
because you don't identify as q anon
does not mean you don't believe what
they believe just because you don't say
well i'm a nazi
doesn't mean you're not a nazi
it doesn't
if you believe fascist things and you're
a fascist
whether you want to admit it or not
you're a
[ __ ] fascist that's how it works
there's no getting around the truth i
mean whether you want to believe it or
not
it's still the [ __ ] truth and making
up a lie and trying to paint over
something
doesn't change it but that's what they
rely on and by they
i mean tucker carlson candice owens
ben shapiro alex jones i mean the list
goes on and on and on and on and on here
folks
that's what they rely on is for these
people
i mean i've heard this kind of [ __ ] have
you heard this [ __ ] from your family
who believe this q anon stuff and you
say the word fascist they say well i'm
not a communist
what what do you mean you're not a
communist well
communist i'm not a communist well
communist isn't fascist
they're not that's not the same thing
actually fascism and communism they're
kind of enemies
one's right wing one's left wing that's
why
republicans call liberals in this
country communist
as if all of us liberals are commies
the reason why is because communism is
your enemy because you're
fascist you're a [ __ ] fascist
i even had this one time when i ask a
friend of mine who is a smart person
he's not a dumb person
at least i didn't question that until i
had this conversation with him
it was after january sixth
and i said or no he said we were talking
about it and he
said well we fought communist in world
war two i said
what no we didn't fight communists we
fought with the communist
he said no he didn't i said yeah we
fought fascism in world war ii
here's what he said here's his his
response from me saying
we fought fascism in world war ii he
said did you call me a fascist
i said no no i did not call you a
fascist
but if the swastika fits
they're distorted folks it's all
distortion
and these people in the media are
playing into this
they're using this that's what ron
desantis is doing when he's talking
about
oh well can we trust juries because
that's what he's saying can we trust
juries
and you're going to hear this over the
next few weeks too this this is a good
one
here's another here's another here's
another um uh
one that they wanna that that they wanna
perpetuate here
is uh cops aren't gonna wanna be
cops because they can't kill people
anymore what the [ __ ]
it's literally that's literally our cut
they're not no one's gonna want to be
cops anymore after this
no one's gonna want to be a cop because
if you
if you're a cop and you have to kneel on
someone's neck for 10 minutes to kill
them for no
good reason and you have to go to prison
for it well that's just
that's just across the line we can't do
that
we're not going to have cops anymore
it's going to be crazy
we just can't do it anymore nope can't
do it
won't be able to manage that
it's all built on these lies
because the only the only way to
perpetuate a lie is to get people to
[ __ ] believe it
i mean if no one if absolutely no one
believes a lie
doesn't work it doesn't [ __ ] work
if no one believes the lie someone has
to believe it
and it's really easy to get these q anon
folks to believe anything they want
so we are going to continue to hear them
uh with these arguments and and the next
the next big thing the next argument
that they're going to make that you're
going to hear over and over and over and
over again
and they're going to perpetuate and
continue to pet you perpetuate until
these q anon
manga trump pumpers just believe it
wholeheartedly
and you're going to hear you're going to
hear you're going to see it in threads
you're going to see it on facebook
you're going to see your family members
saying it on facebook and out loud
you're going to hear them say this well
now that the cop is in prison
racism is over
you're gonna hear that well you must be
happy now mr liberal
you must be happy now blm because
now now that the white cop is in prison
racism is over because one court case
one situation one of them that's it it's
done it's dead
it's what that's the argument they're
going to be making they're going to be
forming this argument over the next
several months because we have eight
eight weeks until
derek chovin is is is sentenced so
they're gonna build this
all the way up to that point and when he
is sentenced
and they lay down the hammer which i
believe there he's gonna have a pretty
big hammer with all three of these
charges being guilty
when they lay down the hammer they're
gonna say see it's all done it's all
done you can't
you can't you can't claim racism and
that's not a thing you could do anymore
you can't do that no more you can't nope
it's over it's done we already did this
we already had this argument now let's
move on to fascism
now let's move on to how to oppress the
rights of other people
let's do that let's move on to that
and let's move on to the lies that we
want to move on to
like voter fraud and
and coronavirus
we're going to have those big arguments
those big huge arguments
because they're fascist
and the trouble is with fascism or any
kind of idea in the first place is you
can't get rid of an idea it's a [ __ ]
idea
uh tucker carlson could go off fox news
air and
he could go retire to the bahamas or
wherever the [ __ ] that bow tie
[ __ ] would want to go
and they'll just be one more right in
this place
one more right in this place and they've
been beating this drum for decades and
decades and decades and decades
to try to get this stuff to stick
and they finally they finally got a
sideshow clown
that would allow them to get this stuff
to stick so that they could say it out
in the open again
i mean but
folks the only thing that's that's more
dangerous
than a fascist we can see is fascists we
can't see
just remember that i'm not saying tucker
carlson
needs to have a show but what i'm saying
as long as they're listening to him
as long as they are listening to him we
need to know what they're saying
and we need to know how it is affecting
it
because the only thing that's dangerous
than an outright fascist
is one you can't see sunlight sometimes
is the best disinfectant
and let me tell you over the last
several weeks it has been more and more
clear
more and more clear that tucker carlson
not only perpetuates and propagates this
white supremacy q anon
[ __ ] but at some level this [ __ ]
might believe it i don't know
i mean i guess today there was a last
night he did a
story on on on his show about how his
yearbook or some [ __ ] about his college
yearbook and
apparently there's a picture of his
college yearbook today
praising the guy who who murdered harvey
milk
now i haven't really dug into that too
much so i don't want to talk a lot about
it today
but again
a fascist you can't see is a hell of a
lot more dangerous than one you can see
out in the open
so take that for what it's worth
for what it's worth and we can't let up
here we got to keep voting
we got to keep having a a public
discourse
about these things um and
and and try and try and try and try hard
to uh uh reprogram
this these these [ __ ] bone-headed
ideas about this q anon stuff
and all the the big lie and and the
extension of the big lie
we have to we have to start getting the
truth out there
and we're not going to do it folks by by
pounding these people with
piles and piles and piles of facts
they're just they're not going to listen
they haven't they won't
listen to facts and statistics and all
that
they don't care about that stuff you
come to them with facts and they'll just
say why it's why it's all the deep state
just do that what you need to do is hold
a mirror in their face
here here's what you look like see see
mr
mr nazi look what you're doing
look how you're acting look what you're
saying
what you're saying is bunkers
absolute bonkers liberals in this
country
are not some scary socialist radicals
that are going to destroy the country
people having affordable health care
affordable accessible health care having
a decent wage
not being in in crippling debt because
of college
being able to retire
is not a radical thing those aren't
radical things
those things don't destroy societies
they do them all over this planet
and it doesn't destroy societies things
like universal health
care that doesn't destroy societies
including ours because we have universal
health care in this country
we have it we actually have us
a couple single-payer systems in this
country
and people don't even realize it and our
society is fine
we need it better but it's fine it's not
it's not
killing our society
of course everyone's going to want to
know proof well
what are those systems of universal
single-payer health care well they're
called they're called
medicare is one of them and the other
one is tricare
if you don't know what tricare is just
look up the united states military and
tricare and you'll find out all kinds of
stuff about tricare
and how that is praised as one of the
the best universal
single-payer healthcare systems in the
entire world
unmatched they'll say unmatched
is some of the words they'll use about
the tricare system
because our military gets that tricare
system and the military deserves those
benefits
and i think they do but we have one here
we have one
we have stuff like that
we have a system to make sure that a
socialist
socialist system to make sure that
people aren't broke when they retire
it's called social security
we've been doing it for a long time
over 80 years i believe if i'm doing my
math right
it happens here these aren't scary
things
they're not like the student loan debt
the united states government that's one
of the things they profit off the most
the government profits off student loans
they profit it's a [ __ ] business
and they insuring back every single one
of them and you think that we can't make
sure that it's affordable for people
give me a [ __ ] break
give me a break stop it stop
acting like this [ __ ] is going to
destroy this country you are a [ __ ]
bonehead i'll tell you what's going to
destroy this country
white supremacy and fascism
we've done this a couple times before
here folks
one of them was called a civil war
and it was over slavery
there's a bunch of [ __ ] white
supremacists
that wanted to make sure they could own
humans property
that didn't work then we fought it as
fascism
it wasn't it wasn't necessarily
inside of our country but there were
nazis here
there were nazis here and you know what
their phrase was do you know what their
little go-to
line was when they were here america
first
america first where we heard that
america first the america first party
the america first caucus
yeah nazis
and how well did that go for hitler and
the nazis
in the 1930s and the 1940s the end
result was fantastic
for them me a break
white supremacy and fascism will not win
because they are bone-headed ideas
and the reason why is because it does
not
equate for humanity
it does not it will not it won't
so good luck to you mr tucker carlson
and ben shapiro and candace owens
and alex jones and donald trump and
ron desantis and jim jordan
matt gatz and ron johnson
mo brooks mike lindell
sean hannity
it's almost like the trump ss huh
i could have a little graphic but i'm
not that good and really on the podcast
you wouldn't see the graphic anyway so
what the [ __ ] the point
i wish i was that good at graphics
but i'm not speaking of that i don't
mean to get off topic here
we're getting near the end here though
we got about 10 minutes left
someone said i did my videos my tic tocs
my videos in front of a green screen
someone said that on a comment today
that i that i do in front of a green
screen i'm like
you have way too much [ __ ] confidence
in
my ability to do as green screen and
paint and paint my road on a green
screen
yeah because you know some days it's
gloomy some days it's
it's did there's snow on the ground some
days it's raining i'm like man i
i am not that good it really is really
simple i hold my phone in my hand
and i yell and scream into it that's it
it's all due just hold the phone and
yell and scream into it record a video
and then
post post post that's it that's all that
happens
and i'm glad that you guys watch it
and i'm glad that
you guys continue to comment
and come watch us here and if you want
to support us on the podcast
that would be fantastic it does cost us
money to publish this
um it's not a ton but you know we
i love i really really like uh to talk
into a microphone if you haven't noticed
but um i i love to express my opinions
and i love that i can do it for an hour
at a time every week here on wednesdays
at three o'clock central four o'clock
eastern
and if you would like to support us you
can go to the website
thetonymichaels.com
you can go to the merch store we have
some [ __ ] stickers there
everyone loves that phrase [ __ ] em so we
got [ __ ] em stickers there we've got
coffee mugs we've even got sweatpants
folks
and if you want one of the hats uh i
i've had several people order hats in
the last few weeks
they just commented a thread hey where
do i get a hat and just go to the
tonymichaels.com the hats are there
you can buy one of the hat the [ __ ]
hats uh and i'm gonna try
this summer we're gonna try to get some
more colorful hats
now some people have requested more
color for hats i i like to wear black
and and gray
so that's that's what we have right now
but i want to you know maybe maybe we'll
do like a red white and blue one for
for fourth of july you know to show our
patriotism
and maybe we'll do some other uh some
other ones and i'm thinking that we do
some trucker hats these these hats here
are flex fit so they're
they're kind of they're kind of pricey
but the the the trucker hats are
much more affordable so maybe we'll do
some of those some different colors and
uh different color schemes so you guys
can you guys can uh walk around in the
grocery store with a [ __ ] hat
and and yeah [ __ ] them you know
whatever you guys want to do when you're
checking out groceries so i appreciate
all your
your support that you guys do give and
uh again if you if you want to you can
you can visit the merch store and
that'll help us out here on the podcast
uh with the publication fees because
that's mainly the fees is
is you got to keep you got to pay them
to keep it posted you know
that's the problem and speaking of that
we did get posted on apple i want to
mention that again on apple podcast
we've been on spotify for a while uh but
we were have tr
having trouble getting it published on
apple podcast but we finally did get it
uh published on apple podcast so that's
good of course
we stream on youtube and we stream on
twitter
uh almost all the episodes are up on
youtube we're still
working on episode 12. they did take it
down apparently i said something that
uh was controversial so i got to figure
out exactly what i said so we can either
take that out of the video
or dispute that exact thing but it's
hard to figure out exactly the thing
that i said that they get mad about
so right now episode 12 is not
on youtube but if you want to catch it
you can go to spotify you can go to
you can go to buzz or just go to the
website and you can
you can find the podcast or go to apple
podcast
and you can find episode 12. it's the
audio version but it's there
it's there you can go listen to it if
you want and maybe
maybe if you listen to it and you decide
the thing that i said that was
controversial that you think they're
banning me for
just you know pop a comment or you know
send something that says hey this is
what it is because i can't
i really can't figure it out i think i
was mocking
someone's beliefs about the vaccine and
that's what they pinged me on
so i haven't been talking about that
lately i want to get a professional on
to actually give us some opinions about
that stuff
but i don't want to get it banned if i
have someone on and we talk
about that stuff and they get all [ __ ]
about it
and then they ban the video well it does
no one any good because you can't you
can't see it then
so uh so we're i'm trying to work around
that but um
i really appreciate you guys uh i have
fun doing this every week and i have fun
doing the tick tocks
um and you guys and and posting on
twitter of course follow me over on
twitter at thetonymichaels.d20michaels
and on tick tock at the tony michaels
again you can find all that at the
tonymichaels.com
you can find it all there so keep
up the good fight um no know that
there is there is 81 million people out
there that voted against this
this garbage and know when they're
talking about
george floyd over the next several
months
and really trying to frame this up that
george
floyd mattered black lives black lives
matter
that is key we need to keep at this we
need to
keep protesting keep talking keep
holding them to account it is very very
very important that we do that and we do
not let up on that
because these fascists are not going to
let up on their arguments they are not
going to let up on this stuff
they're going to continue to say the mob
is ruling and and the
election system's rigged and the courts
are rigged and the jury's rigged in the
deep state
and i'm telling you i'm telling you we
are going to get to a point
they are already showing their cards
where them
on the media the fox news the oans
uh the newsmax uh infowars
they are going to start saying things
like
well what's so bad about fascism that
that's fascism well
if me being a fascist is that well it
can't be that bad
they're gonna start saying things like
that and then it'll start to trickle
down to these q anon people
because they're finally catching on that
what they're what they're saying what
they're propagating is fascism they
thought it was communism the whole time
they thought all communists and fascism
that's the same thing
well they're starting to learn that
they're not the same thing and the
reason why they're learning is because
we're
saying it we're alerting them
we are the ones that are showing them
that this q anon maga trump upping stuff
is white supremacy
at its core is fascism
it's fascism and we
and and to think that this stuff this
authoritarian
[ __ ] does not come and does not have to
do
tie things in like the use of force
uh uh gun legislation with with gun
regulations and gun safety
and and white grievance and white
privilege to think that this stuff is
not all tied in and interlaced together
is bone-headed it is
all it is all tied into this fascism
component
and they are going to continue to beat
this drum
and eventually they're going to admit
that it's the drum of fascism
they're going to admit it right out in
the open well
you're going to hear your q and on
relatives say well if that's what
fascism is
well i guess it's not that bad
i guess it's not that bad maybe maybe
the nazis just weren't that good at it
i'm telling you beware
beware but just
just see it as it is and call it like
you see it
and tell them what it is tell them why
it is that
give them the history of it but don't
bog them down with too many facts cause
these people just can't handle facts
where the [ __ ]
i mean a [ __ ] they just can't handle it
where the [ __ ]
that's why i don't really give them
facts in my videos i just go straight
after them and give them an analogy of
boneheaded [ __ ] that they might be able
to understand so
maybe show them one of my videos i don't
know all right everybody
thanks for joining me today on the tony
michaels podcast
and we'll see you next week wednesday
three o'clock
central four o'clock eastern the same
[ __ ] place
the same [ __ ] time youtube
twitter
come and watch us and if you miss it you
can go over to youtube and you'll catch
clips
on twitter and tick tock so join us next
week
thank you and to all the right wing
fascist manga trump pumping chewing on
[ __ ] out there
[ __ ] em you've been listening to the
tony michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news
no rules no boundaries i think we've
made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon
in the meantime follow tony on social
media
at the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them